bon vous reconnaissez sûrement l'endroit
on est ici pour la partie 3 de la pêche
à l'aimant à lattes donc on a obtenu les
autorisations de la mairie pour retenter
une dernière fois de trouver les objets
surtout retrouver le chargeur qui a été
perdu par un gendarme lorsqu'il sauvait
une personne on l'a déjà dit mais la
gendarmerie a cherché pendant un jour en
plongeant et ils l'ont pas trouvé donc
on est de retour pour la 3e tentative et
on va pas pêcher seul puisqu'il y a
Vincent qui est avec nous et la main
d'oeuvre gratuite alors on a aussi fait
venir les enfants de la ville qui vont
venir nous aider à pêcher donc on les
attend là et je pense qu'on va le
trouver ah normalement c'est sûr là
bonjour
voilà les renforts
alors qu'est-ce qui nous a trouvé
Vincent alors attends bouge pas
bonjour
une table
un leurre de pêche et là regardez une
antenne de voiture c'est original
dans un sac qui était quoi
bon courage en tout cas merci
c'est c'est
un multifonction directeur
bien joué je vais le montrer aux jeunes
je te le mets de côté
on va essayer par là ça vous dit
on va voir ce que Lucas nous a trouvé
une table entière
qui fait mieux que moi
qui va faire mieux que moi une table de
jardin
c'est exactement la même que le resto
tu pourras la ramener chez toi ce soir
tes parents sont contents
trottinette
bien joué
[Applaudissements]
tout à l'heure
encore une fois et de Lucas ah là c'est
lourd hein
je vais tenir comme ça
bien joué
ça y est j'ai des invasives
c'est une poubelle
je suis sur une poubelle depuis tout à
l'heure
c'est bon
[Musique]
on a besoin
[Applaudissements]
je vais essayer de la choper par la
poignée là
une demi-heure maintenant on va
s'éloigner regardez s'il y a pas un truc
dedans quand même ce qu'on a fait
basculer
j'espère
c'est bon il y a rien bravo personne ne
devrait aller voir un psychologue à la
fin de la journée
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore trouvé
le chargeur mais on avance sur ce sujet
là
ça marche
j'espère de France ah ouais
79 c'est pas mal on va créer une maison
on va un peu le nettoyer
[Musique]
bien joué bravo allez vas-y
allez à deux c'est la Clio II non c'est
peut-être encore une table
aujourd'hui je vais ouvrir un restaurant
tu peux te mettre dessus et tourner là
j'ai une planche comme ça chez moi
j'ai une planche comme ça qui permet au
bord de l'eau c'est mieux
c'est normal de pas réussir à l'enlever
c'est
le même
bien joué
[Applaudissements]
de pain sol du coup
bon allez il manquait plus que ça
il y a encore la couleur vase
fais tomber la boule attends
c'est quoi le 6e au moins alors
et ouais ouais ouais sixième pied de
parasol identique
pour de bon on va les vendre en lot
tout doucement
ok attends je vais essayer d'attraper le
bout
on
[Musique]
je crois que c'est bon on a fait
carte d'identité
incroyable c'est bon ça
un briquet une montre une montre
c'est fou ça
peut-être il a même pas été volé il
tombait d'un bateau clairement
une carte d'identité
d'identité ou un truc comme ça
un meilleur travail de la journée bravo
grâce à la carte d'identité on peut on
va pouvoir rendre la montre à la
personne
en plus
il y avait ça aussi
ça c'est un médaillon religieux
ou pas très belle pêche de ramener la
montre on a essayé d'appeler ils ont pas
répondu mais il y a l'adresse sur la
carte d'identité donc on va tenter et
après on va mettre tout ça dans le
camion Vincent vient de nous faire
remarquer quelque chose d'incroyable je
pense que vous avez déjà tous essayé et
je pense que vous êtes peu à avoir
réussi du coup faut garder un trophée
c'est un caddie infini
le vrai caddie volé
je pense qu'il faut le garder du coup
c'est cadeau allez c'est parti merci les
gars bon on avait essayé de restituer ce
qui était contenu dans le sac la
première fois moi c'est juste symbolique
je pense vu l'état mais on va retenter
on était dans le coin donc sinon il y a
les voisins
qui leur transmettra toute manière ça a
pas trop de valeur parce que c'est
symbolique plus qu'autre chose c'est
peut-être la montre ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de savoir depuis quand
il ouais c'est pour ça qu'on aurait aimé
on dirait quelques mois mais bon je
pense qu'on aurait volé le sac à main
parce qu'il y avait toute sa carrière
ou pas
dans le port de Lattes
comme vous voulez si vous voulez
quelques jours après les propriétaires
ne sont passés un appel pour nous
remercier et de donner un petit peu plus
d'informations sur ce mystérieux sac il
s'avère qu'ils ont été cambriolés il y a
10 ans pendant qu'ils étaient absents on
leur a pris le sac à main bien sûr avec
tout leur papier on leur a pris aussi
des ordinateurs portables quelques jours
après leur cambriolages avaient été
retrouvé flottant dans le port une carte
bleue alors non donc ils avaient été
prévenus par le port et il a fallu
attendre 10 ans de plus donc pour
retrouver ce sac là malheureusement on
n'a pas retrouvé le chargeur du gendarme
pendant cette session je pense que ça
devient compliqué et qu'on va abandonner
cet objectif en tout cas ça nous aura
quand même fait trois belles vidéos à
cet endroit et je suis sûr qu'il en
reste encore on se dit à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de
pêche à l'aimant je leur donne bonne
soirée